-How are you?
-I'm very well, thanks.
How are you?
-Good.
I'm very happy to have you here.
We're big fans
of "The Crown" here,
and we kind of completed
the trifecta,
because we had Matt Smith here,
who was Prince Philip.
We had Vanessa Kirby, who was
Margaret, and now we have you.
So, we're very -- very happy
to complete the set.
-The whole set.
-Whole set of royals.
-And now you are not in
the next season of "The Crown"
because you're being replaced
by Olivia Colman,
who is another
fantastic actress.
Did you take anything
when you left?
It seemed like that's
a set where --
a lot of good stuff to steal.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, there'd be loads
of good stuff to steal,
but they keep it under ---
they keep it under lock and key.
I mean, they need it all,
as well.
So they'd know who'd taken it.
It would be pretty obvious.
-Yeah, that's true.
When one cast leaves
and another one comes in,
they have a lot of suspects.
-I deny everything.
I have nothing.
-Do you miss it?
Do you miss playing someone
of that stature?
It must have been nice to be
called Queen all the time.
-No one ever called me Queen.
-Yeah, I guess that's a good
point as I'm thinking about it.
-Walked over, "Hello, Queen."
-Yeah, exactly.
"Oh, Queen,
we got trouble again."
-"Nice to see you today, Queen."
That'd be great if they did.
-Yeah, they should have
done that.
-Yeah. No. They never did.
They never called me Queen.
But I don't miss the stature of
the part, but I miss the people.
-Yeah. I imagine it's very hard
to leave a show like that.
I will say, you know, any actor
would have a fear of,
"Oh, I hope I don't get typecast
in roles like this."
You've certainly shook that off
right away
by going from the Queen to
Lisbeth Salander in this film.
-Yeah.
Or it makes me look like I've
got psychological problems.
-Oh, yeah.
Oh, I hadn't even
thought of that.
That's right.
So, it might be that, as well.
But definitely far more leather
in "Girl With --"
Far more leather
and I'm thinking more tattoos
than "The Crown."
-I mean, I don't know.
You never know what goes on from
the neck down with the Queen.
-That's right.
-She could be hiding
an awful lot of tats.
-That would be a fun thing
to find out.
-Wouldn't it?
-Yeah.
-How could we find that out?
-I don't know.
I guess -- I guess the reality
is, if you haven't found it out,
none of us
are going to find it out.
'Cause you probably did
more research than I did,
and if you never came across
the tattoo part.
-I hope so.
-But I would think the Queen,
if the Queen had a bunch
of tattoos --
and again, this is just me
blue-skying and dreaming.
-Okay, let's do this.
-I wish it was some kind of map.
[ Laughter ]
-Over her whole body or --
-Yeah, like,
just every part of her
that you can't see in clothes,
there's, like, some sort of map
that's very key to the --
-Like a treasure map?
-Yeah.
I mean, she's a queen and so,
you know, they put it on her.
I don't know.
When's it okay to --
Well, no.
She's a royal.
So, it might not
have been up to her.
They might have been like,
"Let's get this map
on this baby, pronto."
Again, I don't know
if this is true or not.
-I'd much prefer if she had,
like, Prince Philip on one arm,
a corgi on the other.
-A corgi, yeah.
-Her handbag just --
-Yeah, but, like,
not just a corgi.
Like, corgi for life.
-All the corgis she's had.
She'd have a sleeve
of all the corgis she'd had.
-Oh, right cause they don't --
I mean, this is a spoiler,
but all those corgis haven't
lived as long as she has.
She's gone through
a bunch of them.
-No, no.
She's gone through loads.
-She's gone through loads
of corgis.
-Yes, there's a really high
corgi turnover.
-Yeah.
They say, you know,
when you're a corgi
and, you know, you're at the --
They go, "Oh, my God.
This is life of the corgi."
And they go, "Yeah,
we don't last that long."
-Yeah.
-Was it fun to -- Lisbeth --
Obviously this is a continuation
of this story.
Was that -- Were these books --
books you were familiar with?
-Yeah, well, I'd read --
I hadn't read the fourth book.
I hadn't read
"Girl in the Spider's Web."
I'd read the "Millennium" series
when they first came out.
-And more -- far more fighting
than "The Crown,"
a lot more stunts.
-Yeah, yeah.
-It was my only criticism of you
in "The Crown."
There were almost no stunts
and fights.
-I know.
Yeah, I didn't do any.
-You didn't do any stunts?
Did you do stunts in this one?
-Yes.
-And did you enjoy it?
Was it something you thought
was important?
Did you think
it would be thrilling?
-I wouldn't say
it was thrilling.
I mean, you sort of try and
approach it as a professional
and not going,
"Yeah, I'm bloodthirsty.
I can't wait to fake-punch
people in the face."
-Yeah.
-But there is an element
that's quite fun.
-Yeah.
I would only imagine.
Plus you're working with people
who are excellent
at not hurting you.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
I would say, like,
if you're a stunt person
whose job is to fight you
in that film,
they really have
a hands-off policy, probably.
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
They know what they're doing.
-Yeah, whereas you're probably
just throwing roundhouses
and hitting them.
-Oh, yeah.
-Left and right.
-Just, you know,
uppercuts and all sorts.
-This was filmed in Stockholm
and Berlin in the winter.
Those are wonderful cities.
I've never been there
in the winter.
They seem very cold and gray.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-I mean, cold more than gray.
They have some beautiful,
crisp mornings.
But, yeah, like subzero,
like, freezing, freezing cold.
-And, you know,
there are a lot of --
See, I mean, again,
a lot of leather,
a lot of helmets,
a lot of motorcycles.
I would imagine, I mean, you're
not riding the motorcycles,
but you were not in a lot
of parkas in this film.
-You must have been cold a lot.
-I was cold a lot there.
I definitely vary in size.
I tried to put as many
thermal layers underneath
as humanly possible,
so sometimes I'm a bit
like a sausage
and some of my leather outfits
are bursting at the seams.
-There are scenes
where you can tell
you can't really move your arm,
yeah.
You're like,
"We got to go over here."
[ Laughter ]
-But -- But yeah.
-How would you even describe
the hairstyle of the character?
-It was mainly a bowl cut
on top,
and then underneath
it was shaved.
It was a bit of a fringe.
I like to mix it up.
Sometimes it was a Mohawk.
-Yeah.
There we kind of looked at,
like, similar haircuts
that had that sort of Mohawk-y,
fauxhawk-y feeling.
-Very similar to Rihanna.
-Yeah, then we got --
-Yeah, and Tilda.
-And then this is Pink
with a little --
That's, like,
a pointy fauxhawk.
-That was quite -- Yeah.
There's more on the sides.
-Yeah.
And then there's that.
-That's the one.
-Yeah, that's the one.
-That's almost identical.
-I feel like it was, maybe.
And then people do always say,
"Oh, my God.
You would make
a great Lisbeth Salander,"
to me all the time.
I was happy for you
that you got it.
I was happy for you.
-That's really kind,
'cause I first said,
"Are sure you don't want Seth
to do it?"
-That's so kind.
I had a feeling
you were a nice person.
So thank you saying for that.